we're in the mixed reality lab of the
University of Nottingham's computer
science school and this is actually the
lab space where quite a few things
happen so it's in a state of perpetual
mess and chaos but this is the little
piece of santi we've carved out we
grabbed this space to set up a virtual
reality Bay running off a vibe which is
usually we use the vibe system for any
sort of virtual reality development but
of course the tech is pretty good the
hardware is pretty good but also it's
the most open system for development
does say opposed the oculus and stuff
like that and it does allow you I will
grab us a crop to use stuff like the
vive tracker which allow you to bring in
other objects accessories and more
interesting virtual reality interactions
then you would in a closed ecosystem
which is why we tend to use it more than
oculus or other technologies last time
we saw one could be far we were looking
at scanning of miniatures 3d scanning
miniatures for various uses and
augmented reality storytelling so we
moved on we're trying to close the loop
a little bit you know take something
physical scan it into a digital asset
that you can use in virtual worlds and
stuff like that so americal in that
video we scanned a bunch of miniatures
that people brought in we put those in a
virtual museum so people could walk
around them like Godzilla sighs no okay
we've gone from the physical to the
digital why not go back to the physical
again so what we did is we started 3d
printing those miniatures you may recall
this guy I think he was the most popular
one on the website back into physical
form at slightly different scales and
then we thought okay how do we push that
envelope a little bit and what can we do
with these things in fact we're still
just a hunk of plastic depending on your
printing technology but usual be just
that so we thought we'd go use a bit of
tech to now start overlaying there's
photorealistic 3d scans your miracle
from the previous video back onto these
physical objects there's a little bit
tricky because you have to know where
this physical object is in space and
there's various ways to do that but once
you've got that and somehow you can skin
this hunk of plastic with a
photorealistic scan you can have some
very interesting interactions the key
point there is locating it how do you
know where it is
well
various technologies all they knew to do
this basically it comes back to locating
objects in space which is not quite a
salt problem I mean we wish we had
indoor GPS but we're not quite there so
you can do things like tracking with
ultra-wideband that's used widely in
robotics you can do stuff with
time-of-flight I mean anybody who's used
recent via the control is the headsets
attract somehow for example this is a
vive tracker just effectively the
controller without the controller bit
and these allow you to track something
in space just by attaching them to
something and then just locating them so
this now verbally can be brought into VR
you can use a newer optical tracking
technologies but those when they work
they're fantastic we're getting them to
work can be a bit tricky when you don't
know what your final object will be or
when that object is sort of malleable so
for now we have been using these in our
VR experiences because they tie in with
the rest of the ecosystem so one reason
to do this would be to haptically
experience objects in different scales
for example here we have that miniature
the original thing was what 28
millimeter scale about an inch tall now
we have something bigger and we can take
that in VR and interact with it at a
larger scale now okay that's not a big
step but if we take something different
like for example the veil vessel virgin
from Chatsworth House the actual statue
is about two meters tall I believe and
here she is in comfortable palm size
more and more museums for example which
is one of the contexts we work with a
lot what they do is they have now
they're not really scanning the
collections so they have vast archives
of 3d models of things so you can
interact with those online on screen in
VR the usual thing walk around it but
again you can't touch it you can't
actually really interact with it things
that would be at a different scale like
the veil Vestals much too large the real
thing do something like this or objects
that are really one-of-a-kind you would
be able to touch like say the crown
jewels for example you'd be able to
interact with them we're in ways you'd
never be allowed
for example a say putting on the crown
jewels or see entire environments that
and buildings that don't exist there are
limitations technology VR is has a few
unsolved problems so seeing as we were
using these trackers these do have some
issues so of course they need
line-of-sight just like the controllers
they are a considerable physical object
that you have to work around you can't
you could just attach it to any object
but then not all that objects are have
this handy sort of way you can attach
them and even if you do what happens is
the first time you do that somebody sees
that hand it to them what do they do
they grab the tracker cuz I think it's a
handy handhold but of course what that
means as you break line of sight and the
tracking fails so you need somehow to
work around that our sort of solution
and you'll see here some of the objects
we ended up using from are using
partners because this was the probably
the best place to launch this
technology's taking putting the trackers
inside boxes the tracking works right
through them but here are some very
practical benefits nobody well no
bidding with normal-size has at least
can possibly grab these trackers and
fully occlude them from the lighthouses
one elephant of the room that haven't
really mentioned is the 3d printing of
these objects now some might say that is
a solve problem 3d printing being well
Traverse technology at the moment but
it's not always the case for starters
you are trying to 3d print 3d scanned
models 3d scanned models whatever
technique you might use my dippy
photogrammetry like we used for the
thrill for the miniatures or something
like a laser scanner which was used to
scan this engine for example they never
produced optimized models optimize
models as the kind you would make from
the ground up for say use in games or
animations and stuff like that those
models always need some cleanup they
have millions of that is more than they
would need to be optimized and often the
models are not ready to use they still
have gaps in them they still have errors
stuff that really doesn't help so with
any 3d printing technique so you have a
few ways to go about that either you fix
the model or you try and use techniques
that ignore them in this case for
example which was a sort of easy object
to fix this was printable and a standard
FDM printer and add the process layer by
layer and everything works fine this
just by depositing material and this is
the kind of commercial 3d printing
technology that you can have in the home
right now so most organizations do have
access to it but something so
complicated as the Eagle aero engine
where you have a lot of very small parts
that are not necessarily very well
supported the problem with an FTM
printer is that you do need to support
the overhangs and the objects that are
not connected during the printing and
then remove those supports quite the job
this one actually was printed by our
partners in the advanced manufacturing
building with one of their let me see if
I get this right sintering printer I
believe and those are very nice in the
sense that they use a laser to Center
powder plastic powder inside basically
been a part of the entire object while
it's being made is suspended in that
powder and you come out with this
fantastically detailed and way stronger
than it looks 3d model all these fine
bits are actually exactly as it came out
the model they may look like errors but
they're not errors in the 3d printing
process rather they are errors in the
laser 3d scanning process that were used
sadly this is not quite ready for
domestic use but maybe we'll get there
even with these technologies they're not
there are objects that are not suitable
for 3d printing so there is a halfway
house that you can use and that was an
empty acrylic box when you have
something that you can't 3d print but
you still want people to be able to
interact with it in VR in some way or
what we did was basically place a
tracker inside this box so we have a
trackable box and in VR we can show a
glass box or something similar the exact
same dimensions but inside this in VR we
can place any 3d model we want whatever
it's something we can't print we can
change it dynamically whatever we want
you can get the halfway house where
people can pick this box up in the real
world picking it up in VR bring it up to
the face rotating it at any angle they
want even the bottom because the bottom
can be see-through in VR and get that
much closer to an object they would not
normally be
able to experience it might be as
resisting something very large now again
in the palm of the hand almost so it is
a bit of a compromise but an interesting
one of that what you put how's it all
work for our purposes and to sort of
begin off with museum context since
we've got objects from the collection of
the Derby Museum not gallery we've
placed them in sort of the setting of
the warehouse of a museum because after
all this is giving you access to stuff
that you normally would not be even have
to be able to see it a museum any museum
can that most have usually less than
half of its collection on display at any
time so we used the Unity game engine
which is together with Unreal probably
the most popular game engine or rather
at this point experience engine to make
virtual reality experiences a pretty
straightforward environment give us
everything we needed to pull together
the various disparate parts of this it's
effectively really a standard virtual
reality set up the biggest problem you
might have for hardware specifications
having our USB ports because each one of
these trackers requires its own USB
dongle which means you've really quickly
run out of them and you didn't realize
it
where it is in comparison to the other
one so we'll ideally get something like
that as you can see our three different
heights around the model then that will
create a sparse point cloud so basically
the between the images it will figure
out interesting points on the model so
features and put those as points in
space